Son mujeres increíbles.
Nunca tuvieron la oportunidad de ir al colegio,
no tenían formación,
ni viajaron, ni contacto alguno.
Mujeres corrientes que han hecho cosas extraordinarias
con su gran coraje,
su sabiduría y su humildad.
Estas son mis maestras.
Durante las últimas tres décadas
he estado trabajando y viviendo en la India,
y he trabajado con mujeres de la India rural.
Nací y me crié en Mumbai.
Cuando estaba en la facultad,
conocí a Jayaprakash Narayan,
un conocido líder gandhiano
que movilizó a la juventud a trabajar en la India rural.
Yo fui a trabajar a los pueblos de la India rural.
Apoyé el movimiento a favor de los derechos territoriales,
el movimiento campesino
y el movimiento feminista.
En la misma línea,
terminé en un pueblo muy pequeño,
me enamoré de un dirigente agrícola joven, guapo y dinámico
que no era muy culto,
pero que era capaz de mover las masas.
Y así, por la pasión de la juventud,
me casé con él
y abandoné Mumbai
para irme a un pueblecito que no tenía agua potable
ni baño.
Sinceramente, mi familia y mis amigos se quedaron horrorizados.
(Risas)
Estaba con mi familia,
con mis tres hijos en el pueblecito,
y un día,
unos años después
una mujer que se llamaba Kantabai vino a verme.
Kantabai me dijo: "Me gustaría abrir una cuenta de ahorros.
Quiero ahorrar."
Yo le pregunté:
"Te dedicas a la herrería.
¿Tienes suficiente como para ahorrar?
Vives en la calle.
¿Puedes ahorrar?"
Kantabai insistió.
Me dijo: "Quiero ahorrar para comprar una sábana de plástico
antes de que lleguen los monzones.
Quiero proteger a mi familia de la lluvia."
Fui con Kantabai al banco.
Ella quería ahorrar 10 rupias al día,
menos de 15 céntimos.
El director del banco se negó a abrirle una cuenta a Kantabai.
Dijo que la cantidad de Kantabai era demasiado pequeña
y que estaba perdiendo su tiempo.
Kantabai no le estaba pidiendo ningún préstamo al banco.
No le estaba pidiendo ayuda o subvención al gobierno.
Lo único que estaba pidiendo era un lugar seguro
para guardar el dinero que ganaba duramente.
Estaba en su derecho.
Entonces me dije,
si los bancos no quieren abrirle una cuenta a Kantabai,
¿por qué no abrir un banco
que dé la oportunidad de ahorrar a mujeres como Kantabai?
Así que le solicité la licencia bancaria al Banco de la Reserva de la India.
(Aplausos)
No fue tarea fácil.
Nos denegaron la licencia
(Risas)
debido a que,
según el Banco de la Reserva, no podían emitirle una licencia
a un banco que va a fomentar a los analfabetos.
Me quedé espantada.
Rompí a llorar.
Y en el camino de vuelta a casa,
seguí llorando.
Le dije a Kantabai y a otras mujeres
que no pudimos conseguir la licencia porque estas mujeres eran analfabetas.
Las mujeres me dijeron: "Deja de llorar.
Aprenderemos a leer y a escribir
y la pediremos de nuevo, ¿qué más da?
(Aplausos)
Empezamos nuestras clases de alfabetización.
Las mujeres venían todos los días.
Estaban tan decididas que después de estar trabajando todo el día,
venían a clase para aprender a leer y a escribir.
Después de cinco meses,
volvimos a hacer la solicitud,
pero esta vez no fui sola.
Me acompañaron 15 mujeres al Banco de la Reserva de la India.
Ellas le dijeron al directivo del banco:
"Ud. rechazó darnos la licencia porque no sabíamos leer ni escribir.
Nos la denegó porque éramos analfabetas."
También dijeron: "No había ningún colegio donde nos criamos,
así que no somos responsables de no haber sido escolarizadas."
También dijeron: "No sabemos leer ni escribir,
pero sabemos contar."
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Incluso desafiaron al directivo:
"Pregúntenos que calculemos el interés de cualquier cantidad principal."
(Risas)
"Y si no somos capaces de hacerlo,
nos deniega la licencia.
Pídale a sus empleados que lo hagan sin calculadora
y a ver quién lo hace más rápido."
(Aplausos)
Ni que decir tiene,
que conseguimos la licencia bancaria.
(RIsas)
(Aplausos)
Hoy más de 100 000 mujeres apuestan por nosotras.
Y ya tenemos un capital de más de USD 20 millones.
Todo eso son los ahorros de las mujeres,
el capital de las mujeres,
y no de inversores externos pidiendo un plan de negocios.
No.
Son los ahorros de las mujeres rurales.
(Aplausos)
También quiero decir que sí,
que tras conseguir la licencia,
Kantabai ya tiene casa propia
y está con su familia
en su propia casa, de ella y de su familia.
(Aplausos)
Cuando comenzamos las operaciones bancarias,
pude notar que las mujeres no podían venir al banco
porque solían perder la jornada laboral.
Entonces, pensé que si ellas no venían al banco,
éste se acercaría a ellas,
y así, se inició el banco a domicilio.
Hace poco, comenzamos con la banca digital.
Para ello, era necesario recordar un número PIN.
Las mujeres dijeron: "No queremos un número PIN.
No es buena idea."
Entonces, intentamos explicarles
que deberían recordar el número PIN,
que nosotros les ayudaríamos a recordarlo.
Se mantuvieron firmes.
Nos dijeron: "Propon otra cosa."
y,
(Risas)
y entonces, dijeron: "¿Y si usamos el pulgar?
Y me pareció una idea genial.
Vamos a vincular la banca digital y la biometría
y así, las mujeres podrán hacer operaciones financieras digitales
usando el pulgar.
¿Y saben lo que dijeron?
Dijeron: "Cualquiera puede robar el número PIN
y llevarse el dinero que ganamos duramente,
pero nadie podrá robarnos el pulgar."
(Aplausos)
Eso reforzó lo que aprendí de las mujeres:
No ofrezcan soluciones deficientes a la gente pobre.
Son gente inteligente.
(Aplausos)
Unos meses después,
otra mujer vino al banco,
Kerabai.
Hipotecó el oro que tenía y tomó un préstamo.
Yo le pregunté: "¿Por qué hipotecas tus joyas
para pedir un préstamo?"
Kerabai dijo: "¿No te has dado cuenta de que hay una sequía terrible?
No hay comida ni forraje para los animales.
No hay agua.
Hipoteco el oro para comprar comida y pienso para mis animales."
Entonces, me preguntó: "¿Puedo hipotecar el oro para conseguir agua?"
No pude responderle.
Kerabai me estaba desafiando: "Tú trabajas en el pueblo
con las mujeres y las finanzas,
pero, ¿qué pasará cuando no haya agua?
Si te vas del pueblo,
¿con quién harás tus transacciones?"
La pregunta de Kerabai era seria,
así que con esta sequía,
decidimos iniciar un campamento de ganado en la zona.
Es un lugar al que los granjeros pueden traer a sus animales
para que tengan pienso y agua.
No llovía.
Así que el campamento de ganado se prorrogó unos 18 meses.
Kerabai solía recorrer el campamento
cantando canciones de aliento.
Kerabai se hizo muy popular.
Llovió y el campamento de ganado se terminó,
pero después de esto,
Kerabai fue a nuestra radio,
la radio de la comunidad,
que tiene más de 100 000 oyentes.
Dijo: "Me gustaría tener un programa habitual en la radio."
El director de la radio dijo: "Kerabai, no sabes leer ni escribir.
¿Cómo vas a escribir el guión?"
¿Saben lo que respondió?
"No sé leer ni escribir,
pero sé cantar.
¿Cuál es el problema?"
(Risas)
Y hoy
Kerabai tiene su programa habitual en la radio
y no solo eso,
sino que se ha convertido en locutora de radio
y la han invitado todas las emisoras de radio,
incluso las de Mumbai.
La invitan y ella hace el programa.
(Aplausos)
Kerabai se ha convertido en una celebridad local.
Un día le pregunté:
"¿Cómo te hiciste cantante?"
Ella me dijo: "¿Quieres que te diga la verdad?
Cundo estaba embarazada de mi primer hijo,
siempre tenía hambre,
pero no tenía suficiente para comer.
Me hacía falta dinero para comprar,
así que para olvidarme del hambre, empecé a cantar."
Que fuerte y sabia, ¿verdad?
Siempre pienso que nuestras mujeres superan muchos obstáculos,
culturales, sociales, financieros,
y siempre encuentran el buen camino.
Me gustaría compartir otra historia:
Sunita Kamble.
Ella hizo un curso en una escuela de comercio
y ahora es veterinaria.
Ella es una dalit,
procede de una de las castas intocables,
pero se dedica a la inseminación artificial en las cabras.
Es una profesión dominada por hombres
y para Sunita, es sumamente difícil
porque ella procede de una casta intocable.
Pero ha trabajado muy duro.
Ha llevado a cabo con éxito partos de cabras en la zona
y es una conocida doctora de cabras.
Hace poco, ganó un premio nacional.
Yo fui a su casa a celebrarlo,
a darle la enhorabuena.
Cuando llegué al pueblo,
vi un póster enorme de Sunita.
Ella sonreía en esa foto.
Me sorprendió mucho ver a una intocable
del pueblo
con un póster enorme en la entrada del éste.
Cuando fui a su casa,
me sorprendí aún más
porque los líderes de las castas superiores,
los hombres, estaban sentados en la casa, en su casa,
tomando masala chai y agua,
lo que resulta muy raro en la India.
Estos líderes nunca van a casa de un intocable
ni toman masala chai, ni agua.
Pero le estaban pidiendo a Sunita
que asistiera y expusiera sus ideas en la reunión del pueblo.
Sunita había roto así condiciones de casta con siglos de antigüedad.
(Aplauso)
Déjenme abordar la labor de las nuevas generaciones.
Estar ante Uds.,
me enorgullece encontrarme aquí,
desde Mhaswad hasta Vancouver.
De nuevo en mi tierra, Sarita Bhise,
ni siquiera tiene 16 años.
Se está preparando,
forma parte de nuestro programa de deportes,
el programa de campeones,
se está preparando para representar a la India en hockey sobre césped.
¿Y saben a dónde irá?
Nos representará en los Juegos Olímpicos de Tokyo del 2020.
(Aplausos)
Sarita procede de una comunidad de pastores muy pobre.
Estoy, no puedo estar más orgullosa de ella.
Hay millones de mujeres como Sarita, Kerabai y Sunita
que también pueden estar alrededor de Uds.
Se encuentran en cualquier parte del mundo,
pero a primera vista, puede que Uds. crean que no tienen nada que decir
o que no tienen nada que ofrecer.
Pues están muy equivocados.
Soy muy afortunada de trabajar con estas mujeres.
Ellas comparten sus historias conmigo,
comparten su sabiduría conmigo
y yo tengo mucha suerte de estar con ellas.
20 años atrás,
estoy tan orgullosa,
fuimos al Banco de la Reserva de la India
y comenzamos el primer banco de mujeres rurales.
A día de hoy, me presionan para que vaya a la Bolsa Nacional de Valores
para establecer el primer fondo destinado a microempresas de las mujeres rurales.
Me están presionando para que abra
el primer banco de financiación de mujeres de todo el mundo.
Como dijo una de ellas:
"Mi coraje es mi capital."
Y yo digo
que su coraje es mi capital.
Y si Uds. quieren,
también puede ser suyo.
Gracias.
(Aplauso)